foreign
happy Thursday everybody I'm Kat but you
can call me Ms tymph if you're nasty
so
let's talk about the Supreme Court and a
law called section 230.
I know what you're thinking cat that has
numbers in it ew gross if I cared about
triple digit numbers I'd look up ratings
for CNN
but if this law goes away it could
destroy the internet as we know it but
don't worry Joey porn will still be
available
so you won't lose your second job
get it you thought I was saying he liked
porn but I'm saying he's in porn
thank you for your service
[Laughter]
so
this week the Supreme Court heard two
cases from families who lost loved ones
in terrorist attacks and those families
are suing social media companies
alleging they should be held liable for
helping Isis one case involved the 2015
Paris attacks it argued that YouTube's
algorithms recommended Isis propaganda
to users the other case claimed Twitter
gave Isis assistance and didn't do
enough to police them from sharing
content
and that's where section 230 comes in it
is a short law written in 1996 that's
said to have created the internet it
goes like this
no provider or user of an interactive
Computer Service shall be treated as the
publisher or speaker of any information
provided by another information content
provider
those words allow the internet to grow
exponentially over the past 25 years
because sites like Google Twitter
YouTube and Facebook could it be sued
over the content users post on their
platforms
now that was great for anyone who loved
free speech
but like when the president climbed
stairs it it comes with the risk
now obviously no one wants to stand on
the side of terrorists even if the fear
of further lawsuits sent Mark Zuckerberg
fleeing to his home planet
imagine how pissed off he would look
and for reference here he is having sex
yeah
but changing
changing this law would open the door
for censoring things other than
terrorism too and once that door is open
it'll be harder to close than Don
lemon's mouth
think about it it's not like Isis
content gets through because big tech
people love Isis of course they don't
Isis isn't vegan
and they don't wear hoodies to work
it's because companies can't catch
everything that everyone is posting all
of the time otherwise they'd be sending
a SWAT team after every creep in my
comments section
check your grandfather's please okay
and we know Isis content is not always
overtly labeled for what it really is
and I get it it's easy to hate big Tech
they Bop around San Francisco drinking
oat milk lattes and acting like they're
so much better than you
well at least whenever they do take a
break from whining about having to come
into the office
if I wanted to hear people about
their cushy jobs I'd have lunch with
Jimmy phela
[Applause]
but recently both political sides have
argued in favor of ending section 230.
for liberals it's about the hate speech
on the platform
of course their definition of hate
speech is broader than a Kardashian's
ass
for conservatives it's about wanting to
hold big Tech liable for silencing or
Shadow Banning their views like crazy
conspiracy theories about gross stuff on
Hunter Biden's laptop which could be
traced back to gross stuff on Hunter
Biden's laptop
but all of the bad things about big Tech
and a desire for your voice to be heard
are exactly why you should want to keep
section 230. if you think big Tech
censorship is bad now just imagine how
many more things would get censored if
these platforms had to worry about
getting sued
it would be like trying to watch the
movie Scarface as if it were edited by
Dana Perino
it would be 10 minutes long and about
dogs
bottom line these platforms would be
most worried about getting sued by those
with the greatest means to do so the
powerful
and if companies like Twitter have to
worry about that and they know that it's
basically impossible to keep track of
everything being posted
don't you think they might just
automatically decide to ban any mention
of those people at all
and when it comes to bad press the rich
and Powerful can be a real pain in the
ass
so without section 230 I'm afraid that
the ability to speak truth to power on
the internet might completely disappear
although I admit if picks from randos
went away I would be very happy
but that's really really not about
speech and I am a firm believer that
free speech is good the answer to speech
you disagree with is never to shut it
down but to answer with your own that's
why I talk so much
I do it for my country
plus blaming a social media site for
what a person posts makes about as much
sense as blaming a gun for what a person
shoots
did it work for Alec Baldwin and it
ain't gonna work for us
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he was the half in Two and a Half Men
retired Marine Corps come on he's
laughing Fox ignition Johnny Joey Jones
she's not angry that's just how she
talks co-host of the five Judge Jeanine
hero
he looks like Peter Pan if he grew up to
run a hookah bar
comedian host of the new show who the
bleep is that Jeff dye foreign
to make his wooden clogs my massive
sidekick and the nwa's World Heavyweight
Champion Tyrese
[Applause]
okay so yeah I I chose this as a
monologue topic because a lot of
liberals and a lot of conservatives hate
section 230 and I just guess I haven't
had enough people yelling at me
um
Joey do you think that there's any
validity to the concern that repealing
it would end up censoring conservatives
more
sure but also like if you break it you
buy it is where I land on this so I
believe in section 230 I believe the
internet should be a place of Free
Speech but you kind of have to turn it
back around the social media companies
and say once you start censoring you're
liable for censoring so now you're
curating so I think like it's really
more of a bluff than anything of like
you know hey social media companies if
you want it to be free speech Let It Be
Free Speech and don't edit anything off
there so it's either one or the other
the other has to be a Post-It board or a
curated presentation and that's the
problem I mean maybe this isn't as easy
as a partisan talking point for the
first time in politics for a while I
mean it's like you know we hate Twitter
but we like Elon you know it's like we
hate electric cars oh but they're built
in America there's some Duality here
um maybe big Tech isn't the worst but
it's also not the best I think
Springport has their work made out for
them for me I think social media is an
absolute destructive thing to America
but Fox knows who I am because I had a
Twitter so yeah yeah Tyrus you were
saying in the green from that if social
media ever went away you have no idea
what you would do yeah yeah
boy
this is the part where I tell you guys I
was really high
no you know what I I
agree with John this there has to maybe
we come up with 231 yeah and we add a
thing to where if you knowingly because
the biggest problem with Twitter before
Elon bought it was that they were
knowingly censoring and deciding what
was newsworthy and what was not to favor
a party so in that case the people who
did that should be held accountable
maybe not Twitter itself is kind of
almost like with politicians they have
qualified immunity which is something I
think that needs to be adjusted if you
knowingly go out and push hate speech or
willing to go after a group because you
don't agree with their beliefs you
should be held accountable for that so
maybe you don't get to sue Twitter but
the CEOs who sat around with their
lattes deciding that we don't need to
hear what Johnny Joey has to say because
he works for Fox they should be
available yeah yeah they should be held
liable so there's got to be let's split
the diff you know what I'm saying 231
and I'm sorry I was high paragraph Z
okay
so
judge you are a judge and uh you know I
guess an egg yes your introduction so I
mean what Joey says the law is 26 words
it doesn't allow anything so that that's
a good point that you bring up and
that's a lot of people are saying that
you know you need to amend it or add
something else what do you think will
happen here the problem with Section 230
is that um it doesn't provide
um protection for certain people let me
explain what I mean by that if you allow
anything to go on the internet which is
I think free speech at its best but the
problem is if you prioritize certain
speech and if you allow certain speech
that maybe is defamation or maybe libel
then the issue is whether or not you
should be liable the way a publisher is
so the question is 230 is a platform
that book right there if there are lies
in Greg gutfel's book you could sue the
Publishers there are okay but I'm not
saying that you could sue the publisher
so I'm not so sure that social media
should get away with letting anything on
their platform and saying we have
nothing to do with it because you know
everyone has a bias everyone has a
particular agenda we found that out from
because of Elon Musk and so I think
there has to be some regulation they
can't willy-nilly let anything on
without being responsible in some way
and so people who are maybe you know end
up being a terrorist because they
learned about something on the Internet
well maybe the internet maybe these
platforms should be more careful about
certain things I'm not saying suppressed
speech but recognize when speech is not
truthful and when they're prioritizing
speech as compared to other speech
I would just like to add that
don't sing don't let anything
willy-nilly on can also be good advice
in other areas of life
oh
Jeff uh you I want to really get you in
here because you are well respected as
the country's number one United States
code comedian
I am the number one non-trans cruise
ship comedian in 2020.
that's a fact
thank you no I'll admit when I don't
know stuff you know I uh by the way that
is a good thing yeah so many people dig
their heels in with stuff they know
nothing I tried to read I don't know I
didn't I don't I don't it's too complex
for me I don't understand I don't know I
don't have any answers I'm not
complaining but I also have no solutions
for it it seemed like a lot I was going
to agree with this like I couldn't I
just liked the idea when I before I read
it I thought that there was like Isis
had a guy that was like in charge of
their Facebook page you know like a
picture like a guy being like you're not
very good at this just run the socials
you've been poked by Isis they're like
what I don't know but then I started to
read it I was like I don't know anything
about this but right if that were if it
were that simple and Isis was like
verified as Isis they're like oh maybe
don't let them on turns out it's way
more complex and I leave it to others I
I really don't know anything about this
one you know what I do think you can
have
you just cheered him for knowing nothing
you gotta love it
but I still think there is a free speech
Yes but there are consequences for what
you say so if you if you want to stand
by what you say understand there are
consequences and we seem to be living in
a time where nobody wants consequences
they just want all their feelings to be
facts and no one to ever check them so I
it needs to be a check well that's the
problem with anonymity on Twitter also
because I can just make up a thing and
then say a bunch of crazy stuff how do
you hold them accountable well the
problem here is I go to the you know
judge you said something about like if
you know it's not fat you if you have
fact Checkers at all now you're liable
for everything that isn't a fact that
you don't label not a fact that's the
problem right it's like if you just say
hey it's on there you decide if you want
to believe it that's and that that is
section 230 right yeah
that might be true how about child
pornography I mean that's too easy you
can't just say I'll let them put on
whatever they want no there has to be
some accountability some responsibility
inciting to Riot child pornography all
kinds of defamation as you say you don't
know who saying it but if you allow this
knowingly allow it and we know it from
Elon Musk and we know from Twitter if
you allow this kind of thing to
proliferate you know then there are
consequences
we do have to go to break but you guys
are all invited to come over to my
apartment later we can continue to Hash
this out okay all right great okay
perfect
yeah okay that's your exact address hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else